Hello everybody, Dr. Kevin Conner's again. Welcome to this episode of Dr. Conner's Live.
Sharing some answers to some questions that viewers have emailed us. And again, if you have
questions, make sure you just email them to info at Conner's clinic.com. That's info at
COA. The ERS clinic.com where we try to answer all those questions. So this question today is
how to deal with pain naturally. This is sort of a cancer patient, but this could be for
anybody. So dealing with pain from a natural perspective, trying to stay away from insads,
trying to stay away from opioids in any of the heavier medications like Fritzville,
and stuff would be highly advisable by I think anybody. So what are some ways that you could
deal with pain naturally? Well, some of the issues are any herbal approach to pain is not
going to be as quick and as effective as anything even over the Conner medication. So let's just
make that straight. So don't think that it's going to be. But chronic pain issues can be dealt with
a lot by anti-inflammatories. So some of the anti-inflammatories that we use in our office are
curcumin, Boswellia, White Willow Bark, Ginger, the beta lanes from those are the enzymes
that are found in beet products. So we have several supplements that we deal with with that.
The limitless from evolve is the beta lane product. Curcuclear is our high dose curcumin and our
clear inflamed product is a mixture of some of the good curcumin, the Boswellia, and
Corsatin and some other really good herbals, Stingy dental and such that are great anti-inflammatories
for chronic inflammation. Acute inflammation like an injury is going to take a little bit more
horsepower than any of those. It can be beneficial using those, but an herbal approach like that is
mainly for chronic inflammation. If you've got a horrible headache, there's nothing that's going to
touch it like an unsan or a medication. So we don't want to pretend. Now somebody with chronic
inflammation from a disease like cancer or something like that wants to try to avoid being on a
more feed any of the opioids or anything like fentanyl, if it's all possible because of the
side effects that it does to your body, not just the constipation, but it can damage cell membranes
and it helps cause us to slide downhill. So the problem is we don't want to have chronic pain
like that. This heavy chronic pain can be very damaging to our bodies too. So what do we use with
curcumin advice? Well, and such, you're just not touching this. From a natural perspective,
you really have to go to the CBD type products then. Hydro CBD, that doesn't have any THC in it,
can be effective. We've had some people be on Hydro CBD and be able to get off opioids.
Typically, you have to go to the THC type products. Now that's out legal at our state unless you
have serious disease like cancer or you could get your green card. But what states that I'll do
allow over the counter THC use, that's the psychoactive portion of the marijuana plant. You do have
to be careful of just the side effects of the psychoactive issues. So you want to make sure you
consult somebody in your state that makes it legal. So I'm not going to talk a lot about the THC
because you know, you do have to deal with the legality of your state. That's the thing that's
supervised. If you do have cancer, make sure that you look at the possibility of getting
THC product that typically it's going to be in a pill form or a tincture form. If it's legal to
smoke marijuana or to buy it over the counter so that you could bake it in a baked good, that is one of
the best ways to deal with pain from a chronic perspective. We've had numerous patients that
live in states that it's legal to do that and utilize marijuana in that way. And it's always a little
bit of an issue like, oh my gosh, I want to stay legal. I've never even smoked a cigarette in my life.
But you got to remember marijuana isn't herb and used properly for proper medicinal purposes.
There's nothing wrong with doing that. It can be extremely effective. It's so much more natural
than some of the paid medications that are on the market that can have so much side effects and
damaging issues. So again, for chronic inflammatory paid, the natural anti-inflammatories, like
curcumin, which is the active form of turmeric, the Boswellia, the beta lanes from beats,
beat products. And again, you'd really need to get that limitless product, some of the powdered
beat products that are on the market. I'm just going to have like literally 120th 100th of the
beta lanes as the limitless, that's a patented product. Products like our clear inflable or curcuclear
are extremely effective for that. The severe pain that can be due to cancer, you're going to really
have to go to a CBD product. We have numerous in our store because it's legal to sell that anywhere
in the country. But the more severe cancer type pain, you have to go to a THC product.
And you can contact our clinic again on our website. If you have any questions about that,
we'll gladly help you with questions about products at our store as well. Again, if you like
this podcast, make sure that you, we really do appreciate it if you like it. If you share it on
Facebook for others to see, we're just trying to get the word out. If you want to talk to myself or
one of my other practitioners in the office, contact the office or visit our website, probably
best choice. And you can see what we do offer. Again, thank you very much. And send your questions
into info at colorsclinic.com. And we'll try to get them answered on our podcast. Appreciate it. Bye-bye.